and I can't swear no okay good
oh yes it's Internet hi everyone a tube
coke over here some of my favorite
YouTube videos that get me through the
hangover days or every day as I call
them basically my favorite thing but is
just watching Kelso virus is a marriage
proposal rejections it makes me so happy
to just see the crushing this I really
can't imagine doing that you know that's
that's under pressure in it cuz queue
for forcing your love on other people
trying to watch sports no how do you
like that I heard just having dinner and
your love oh shut the [ __ ] up I'm cool I
hope it's crippling I hope you never get
over it
just I live my life and you're just
proposing to a sex your mom was watching
I hope your mom and dad were in the
audience and watched you fail you idiot
sorry sorry love is real and you know
everyone fight there's someone out there
for everyone whatever probably get over
them 1012 years ago the next one is just
a sketch by Pete Holmes called
lightweight James Bond vodka martini
shaken not stirred
this is the sketch where they're filming
the new James Bond movie and they have
to film with real vodka drunker and
drunker and it's such a simple sketch
but it's done so well tell me everything
I know about Skyy right there are so
many cool but like empty and we get that
weird boy in here there is weird boy
we're getting out weird boy probably
sleeps in a racecar bed and then me and
my flatmates it was wall pasta show and
someone else will be in and you'll just
hear someone screaming the words I'm a
bag boy and I could do what I please
caviar vodka martini with Chase next one
this is just a sporting one which will
mean nothing over here in the States
because it's it's football real football
like you know when you kick a ball with
a foot it's when Fernando Torres while
he was playing for Chelsea scored the
winning goal against Barcelona in the
Champions League semi-final it was a
game where we were absolutely getting so
lot 'red and Torres had cost 50 million
and he'd scored like two goals in a year
all their players need to scroll one
more goal to win it's the 92nd minute we
clear the ball and just suddenly it's
just our ace and just the goalkeeper
and the guy commentating orgasms heat
orgasms at the point is nicaya their
voices goes
[Applause]
there's no other explanation of the
liver the height that he came on his
pants
I made the exact same noise for just
much girlier when I watched that live
just like oh it was a great save the
greatest greatest card of day he's a
weird one Rebecca Black Friday but
Brock's dub 7 a.m. waking up in the
morning it just gets really funny videos
and he just dubs over them with the
weirdest voice overs gotta get down to
the bus stop gotta catch my bus I see my
friends and it makes no sense
everybody's lookin forward to the
weekend so there's no context it's
routine but it's just funny I love I
love stupid stuff looking forward to the
weekend
[Music]
thanks for watching i'm daniel sauce and
never ever ever propose in public you've
selfish [ __ ] would you give birth in
public no you wouldn't right so one day
in one day we are sitting one of the
most remarkable Champions League stories
for many years
[Applause]
[Music]